>> Sherer: Welcome to Atlanta and Emory University
>> Rhodes: Thank you
>> Sherer: So tell me a little about yourself
>> Rhodes: Well I’m a wife and a mother,
I’ve got two grown children and a husband of
about 39 years now. And I worked in New York
City advertising for about 27 years, a very
stressful job. But now I work as a patient
advocate and I’m a writer.
>> Sherer: So why is February 25, 2009 forever
etched in your mind?
>> Rhodes: Well because that was the day that
I gave up. That was the day when I cried uncle.
And it had a lot to do with the stress of
my job and that time of my life. I woke up
in the hospital the next day, or two days
later, no one could have been more surprised
than I was to have been as ill as I was with
depression. So that was the turning point
for me. That was when I realized – oh I
– February 2009 is going to be my new life.
>> Sherer: So how did your family react to
the fact that you tried to take your own life?
>> Rhodes: Well I think first of all they
were shocked just as I was. I mean nobody,
nobody knew how ill I was with the depression.
So the first reaction was utter disbelief
because I was somebody who had everything
going for her: long-term marriage, two great
kids, corner office in a big New York City
advertising agency. There should be no reason
why I would want to kill myself. And yet because
my brain wasn’t working and I didn’t realize
it I just became – I just gave up. So for
them to see me as someone who gave up, because
in their eyes I was someone who was a fighter,
I was someone who had a great game face. I
could pretend that I was happy. I could pretend
that I could get the job done, because of
this game face that I managed to perfect.
And it was out of that, when that mask came
off, that everybody went “whoa” we almost
someone special to us.
>> Sherer: So as you know back in the mid-1990s
there was some research done here at Emory,
funded by the federal government, that helped
bring TMS therapy to market. So how has TMS
therapy changed your life?
>> Rhodes: It has saved my life. TMS is new.
It was something that when I tried it I wasn’t
sure if it was going to work. I call it the
F.U.D. factor; Fear, Uncertainty, and Doubt.
But when I got through the initial therapy
and I felt the lift from what I call emotional
nausea. Which is waking up every morning with the most disgusting “ick” feeling, worse
than, 10,000 times worse than “Oh I gotta
go to work it's Monday morning feeling.”
I realized that TMS was going to be therapy
that was going to work for me. It’s my go
to tool in my doctor’s toolkit to keep me
healthy, to keep me well. My life is redefined.
I feel clearer, I feel more centered. Before
when I was on medication I always felt like
I was watching, my life was like being in
a video, watching a video. Since I’ve done
TMS and I’m no longer taking medication
I feel like sitting here with you is the experience
one would have being at a live theatre production
as opposed to a movie. It’s real. Life is
real because of TMS.
>> Sherer: It took a while to get to the point
where TMS was available, I think there was
a year in between your initial attempt at
suicide and when you were finally able to
get the relief from TMS. Tell me what that
year was like.
>> Rhodes: That year was the lost year. I
call it the lost year. It was waking up every
morning with that disgusting feeling. If I
got out of bed, although I was sleeping 14-16
hours a day, I would then move to agitation
and anger that I still had to be here. Then
I would move to tears and then I would be
back in bed by 8:00 at night. I didn’t socialize,
I never returned phone calls, it was a dead
year. And then finally when I was able to
get insurance coverage and I started TMS therapy
my life changed completely.
>> Sherer: Tell me just a little more about
how the TMS therapy works.
>> Rhodes: Oh it’s great.
>> Sherer: It’s not like taking a drug.
>> Rhodes: No it’s great.
>> Sherer: Like you are with anti-depressants.
>> Rhodes: It’s great. First of all it’s
so easy. This is what really surprised me.
You think you know that you are going to get
your brains zapped with this coil pushing
MRI strength pulses into your head. You go
in, I went in, I sat down in a spa chair,
there was TV or music available to me to watch.
While the pulsing, it’s a coil that fits
in a device that’s curved to the head. It
sits on the left side of the head. The worse
part was getting use to the tapping which
took about a week. It’s an intense tapping
but there after your in and out in 45 minutes.
I could drive myself to and from my treatments,
I didn’t have to have someone shepherding
me and having to take time off from their
job to get me to my treatments. When I would
leave I wouldn’t have any upset tummy, I
didn’t have any disorientation, or sleepiness.
It’s almost like this is it? There’s nothing
to it, except for the fact that you have to
be patient because it’s a cumulative process.
So it starts out at the outer most part of
the prefrontal cortex. Over time the neurons
start waking up further and further into the
brain which is where all of the neurotransmitters
and all of the action happens in the brain
to adjust mood, to make me feel better. So
that patience, being able to get through.
It took about two or three weeks before I
felt the lift. So just being committed, being
trusting, and believing, and getting over
the F.U.D. factor.
>> Sherer: So there’s plenty of information
that shows anti-depressants and their affects
are not necessarily sustainable, that they
may work for a while but not later. Is there
information yet on TMS and how sustainable
the benefits of that will be?
>> Rhodes: Yes they have done just recently
a study that was done proves that TMS is durable
for at least six months and for me it was
even longer. But it’s like anything else
you need to maintain, there’s no silver
bullet, no get out of jail free card here
with TMS therapy. If I were on a medication
I would have to make an appointment with my
doctor, get my medication reviewed, adjusted,
he writes a prescription, I go every month
and I get a new prescription. It’s the same
thing with TMS. Now after I’m in my fifth
anniversary, I’ve been doing this for five
years, I now realize that if I go once a month
one TMS treatment it will keep me ahead of
the depression symptoms – that chronic major
depressive disorder serves up. I know my symptoms
now, that’s the good news is that I can
tell when I’m starting to get low. Then
I go for one treatment. Let’s say I go for
a treatment on a Friday afternoon by Sunday
afternoon I feel the lift. The teariness has
gone away, the feeling of agitation it dissipates
because my brain has been stimulated and it
is again reminded its got to do its job.
>> Sherer: Why is it so important for you
to be an advocate for TMS?
>> Rhodes: Well for one thing when I did this
in 2010 nobody knew about it. I was one of
the first patients in the country to try it.
But my remission was so remarkable to me that
when people would say “Martha you look great,
what are you taking?” I said I’m doing
TMS, what’s that, nobody knew about it and
to this day there is still not enough critical
mass for patients to realize that there is
viable, safe, FDA cleared therapy that’s
an alternative to traditional medications
and other therapies. Again it’s not a cure,
it’s a tool that doctors now can have as
an ad-in to their tool kit. And patients who
are not going to respond to mediations, and
there are many of them. Many of us who will
not respond to medications or become immune
to them over a period of time if you have
had a lifetime of depression and you’ve
been on medications for that length of time.
Sometimes you start to build up a resistance
to them which is what I think happened to
me and so now I have this once a month TMS
treatment. I tell people about, I wrote a
book about it because I knew that if I could
just get the word out, if I could just let
people know that there’s hope. There’s
an answer to those that are just struggling
with not having relief from medication then
it was to me important. So I now advocate,
spend a lot of time with it. And I have another
theory it’s called do good to feel good.
For me if I’m helping someone else, if I’m
doing good for someone else, and putting my
attention over there with you or with another patient, anybody I feel good. That’s part
of my own therapy for keeping depression,
my depression daemons at bay.
>> Sherer: Well thanks Martha. Thanks for
coming to Emory and helping explain how TMS
has changed your life and be well.
>> Rhodes: Thank you very much for giving
me the opportunity to share my story with
you. Thank you.